so can you uh elaborate on the idea of
free speech absolutism
so
hate speech
can be quite painful to quite a large
number of people does this worry you yep
living in a free Society
requires that you expose yourself to
some discomfort you call it pain
it's maybe emotional pain it's not
physical pain
um
but
it's uh it's the price we pay for living
in a free Society every so often we're
insulted
we're emotionally hurt
think of the alternative all the
alternatives are worse nobody ever
promised us a Rose Garden
we're lucky to be in a country that has
the First Amendment it's also the oh
it's the most diverse country in the
world
because of immigration
I mean my my grandparents My Father's
Side came over from Russia on my
mother's side came home from Poland
I'm very happy that my grandparents came
in from Russia
oh I would not want to be in Russia
today I'd probably be
sharing a cell with a Wall Street
Journal reporter
um so um I'm thankful that they came in
and um this is a great country it's got
troubles right now but our country
doesn't and we've had before we had a
civil war we had segregation uh we had
the decimation of the Indians we're not
perfect
but it's the best place in the world for
somebody who values Liberty so you don't
think that hate speech can Empower large
groups
that uh
eventually lead to physical action to
physical harm to others no I don't I
think that
that
um we have developed a culture in which
um it's understood that if you don't
like what you hear you you talk back
um you write
you write something um
we don't punch each other we insult each
other
um it's insulting great well I don't
know it's okay I used to as a kid in
Brooklyn where I was born I was born
raised in Bensonhurst we used to say
Sticks and Stones can break by bones but
names can never harm me and it's
absolutely true if what was true when I
was five is true and I'm I'm almost 81.
so I've lived a long time I've seen it
all
and I'm talking from experience as well
as Theory
it's what happens when you reach your
80s